la unión europea ha conseguido llenar el
80% de sus almacenes de gas para hacer
frente así a posibles restricciones por
parte de rusia se produce este objetivo
dos meses antes de lo previsto aún así a
pesar de ser una cifra muy alta no sería
suficiente en caso de que moscú
decidiera cortar por completo el gas a
toda la región por ello la comisión
europea ha firmado nuevos contratos con
otros países como por ejemplo para
aumentar las importaciones de gas
natural licuado proveniente de eeuu
también con qatar argelia egipto o
israel aún así la comisión europea
insiste hay que seguir aumentando estos
almacenes no sólo al 80 hay que seguir
aumentando porque todo esto se produce
en un momento en que los precios del gas
están marcando récords absolutos la
cifra alcanzada hoy se produce justo
cuando la compañía estatal rusa gazprom
ha anunciado que reducirá los flujos de
gas hacia francia y también que
suspenderá para los próximos tres días
el envío de gas hacia alemania por
supuestas labores de mantenimiento algo
que se produce en poco más de un mes es
la segunda vez que algo así se produce
aún así rusia está bombeando mucho menos
de lo previsto gas a alemania